actually i'm curious if you agree with  this i say it's not necessarily about  the money like if a guy won the lottery  if he's broke wins the lottery i don't  think he becomes hot it's about the  skills he like acquires in getting money  like his work ethic his drive um usually  comes with some sort of competence would  you agree with that or disagree no i 100  percent agree i get i get presented that  point a lot so to that i normally say  that what gets forgotten and all this  red pill stuff because it's money  muscles game frame okay  but these blue collar men they're very  hot there's nothing sexier than if your  man fixes your sink without calling the  plumber you know what i mean oh my gosh  yeah  just is your man resourceful  that's all women need i think jordan  peterson says it's usefulness like  across the board that's what women are  attracted to